дуже
популярним став інструмент електронних
каталогів Як ви знаєте закупівельне
законодавство від початку війни в нашій
країні зазнавали уже багато разів змін
На жаль поки я не можу сказати що ці
зміни Вже остаточні напевно і надалі ми
ще будемо мати певні коригування вони
необхідні для того щоб адаптуватися під
ту ситуацію яка є із процесом здійснення
закупівель однак інструменти електронних
каталогів на сьогоднішній день
передбачений як альтернатива відкритим
торгам саме на це я хочу звернути вашу
увагу якщо вартість вашого предмета
закупівлі перевищує 100 тисяч гривень і
товар який ви збираєтесь придбати
наявний в електронному каталозі то ви
можете одразу придбати його в
електронному каталозі в чому основна
перевага цього інструменту в тому що вам
не треба здійснювати кваліфікацію
постачальника не треба розбиратися в
технічних програма трохи тому як їх
виписувати вам треба лише скористатися
вже готовим продуктом для вас
централізована закупівельна організація
яка є адміністраторами про яку колеги
далі детальніше розкажуть вже здійснила
всі ці дії і на сьогоднішній день ми
маємо дуже гнучкий інструмент який
дозволяє швидко забезпечувати ваші
потреби Саме через електронний каталог
крім того оскільки законодавство
насправді дуже динамічний закупівельне
зараз і я знаю наскільки важко вам
слідкувати за цими змінами враховувати
їх в своїй роботі додатково Я хочу
анонсувати вам що Міністерство економіки
як уповноважений орган
розробило
два онлайн-курси вони абсолютно
безкоштовні вони розміщені на платформі
Прометеус зараз сюди в чатик я вам кину
посилання на Ці курси дуже раджу вам
реєструватися проходити дивитися і
ознайомлюватися з тим як у нас зараз
працює закупівельне законодавство в тому
числі Там дуже багато інформації в
контексті того що ми тепер країна
кандидат до приєднання до європейської
спільноти І в цьому контексті наші
закупівельне законодавство буде
зазнавати подальших змін для
гармонізації із законодавством
Європейського Союзу тож також у цих
речах вам треба буде розбиратися
орієнтуватися для того щоб підготуватися
вже зараз до того що нас чекає після
нашої Перемоги до відновлення
нашої країни до відбудови нашої країни я
раджу вам вже зараз реєструватися і
ознайомлюватися з тим як можуть
працювати певні інструменти які ще зараз
не застосовуються в нашому
закупівельному законодавстві але будуть
використовуватись на майбутнє в тому
числі я хочу сказати про те що
інструмент електронних каталогів як
альтернатива відкритим торгам планується
зафіксувати на законодавчому рівні і в
подальшому Коли уже нарешті настане наша
перемога коли ми вже з вами будемо
працювати не попідзаконним актом а по
законодавству то зараз є така ініціатива
відкоригувати це законодавство внести
туди зміни і залишити цю можливість
використовувати електронні каталоги як
доступний простий зрозумілий зручний
інструмент для закупівельників для
замовників вже на законодавчому рівні
тож я передаю слово своїм колегам з
централізованої закупівельної
організації які поділяться дуже детально
з вами Як цим користуватися бажаю вам
плідного дня і Тихого спокійного для
того щоб отримати ці знання Дякую всім
пане Євгене перед тим як ви починаєте
презентацію Я ще раз дозволю собі
зупинитись на технічних моментах дорогі
друзі нас 450 людей в чаті Я останній
раз наполегливо прошу особливо тих які
користуються зумом із мобільних
телефонів або з планшетів де там по
легенькому дотику може включитись
мікрофон слідкувати за своїми
мікрофонами Ну я не матиму можливості
постійно вас глушити коли ви щомете тому
я просто буду виключати вас із
конференції запис ви зможете взяти в
навчально-методичному центрі разом із
тими посиланнями які пані Тетяна нам
зараз скіни в чат для реєстрації на
навчальні курси
ось
користувач Буг
вас особливо це стосується
на цьому організаційний момент все пане
Євгене прошу вам слова
Доброго ранку всім колегам всім
присутнім на сьогоднішній зустрічі Дякую
пане Тетяна за гарний вступне слово
дякую колегам з Міністерства освіти і
науки за те що допомогли нам
організувати
сьогоднішні
вебінар навчання зустріч можна називати
це по-разному по-різному на тому такі
зустрічі з замовниками Ми намагаємося
останнім часом проводити досить часто
наша в тому числі задача
ну зустрічається популяризація прозора
маркетон відразу хочеться ну задати таку
рамку що і сказати що прозора марки там
це не є новим продуктом да І сьогодні ми
не презентуємо там прозоро маркети якщо
щось нове і там
невідоме для
державних замовників для заку
письменників які щодня здійснюють
закупівля в рамках нашого національного
законодавства але все ж таки ну ми там
переслідуємо декілька цілей там в тому
числі нам би хотілося е-е все ж таки ще
раз показати і розкрити всі можливості
потенціал прозоромаркету для тих
закупівельників замовників які не мають
досвіду да закупівель через прозоро
марки Та бо мають досить там обмежений
досвід або мають там негативний досвід
все ж таки ми би хотіли показати
що прозоро марки це реально і працюючі
інструмент Ну і друга Мета - це все ж
таки я сподіваюсь що більша частина
присутніх в тому числі людей які там тим
чи іншим чином пов'язані з закупівлями
Вони все ж таки знайомі більше чим
меншій мірі з
дехто активна використовує маркетинг Ми
би хотіли можливо почути від людей саме
активних користувачів
деякі зауваження пропозиції питання тому
в принципі Ми Точно Там готові
відповісти на всі питання Якщо є
можливість можете задавати питання в
чаті
наприкінці зустрічі ми залишимо там
деякий час
на
живі відповіді на ваші питання можна
буде
питання будуть задати вголос якщо ти там
можливість є тому в принципі Ми сьогодні
там плануємо продуктивно активна з вами
попрацювати перед тим як розказувати
прозоро марки да хотілось би познайомити
в принципі з нами втоми яку роль ми
відіграємо державну установа професійні
закупівлі я її керів Євген ми є першою
централізованою закупівельної
організації в Україні Яка взагалі була
створена Да в 2016 році
перший нашою одною основних наших е-е
напрямків нашої роботи на етапі
створення це було і залишається ми є
централізованою закупівлювальною
організацією проводимо обов’язкові
закупівлі для центральних органів
виконавчої влади по деяким визначеним
категоріям ну зараз це електроенергія і
нафтопродукти Ну і
починаючи на етапі створення прозора
Маркету Да в 19-му році наша дзо
державного установа професійні закупівлі
була визначена
адміністратором електронного каталогу
prozorro Market
далі трошки більше розкрию що таке
адміністратор прозора Маркета але ну
тобто починаючи з початку існування
прозоро Маркету Ми
є його одним із його адміністраторів
якщо розглядати всю систему
екосистему да то можна сказати що
прозора марки не є якимось
[музика]
прозора маркет не є якимось
відокремленою платформою
Він все ж таки є частина великої
екосистеми прозора з якою точно думаю ви
всі знайомі Да На верхівці цієї системи
є звичайна державна підприємство прозора
яке в принципі
Ну Має там головну роль вони є головним
адміністратором всієї центральної бази
даних прозора частиною якої є прозора
марки вони фактично там
відповідають за підтримку цієї системи
Да і вони там все ще технічні
нововведення зміни в системі Це все зона
відповідальності прозора Маркетом
ДП прозоро вибачаюсь Да що стосується
прозора маркети наразі в Україні
визначено три адміністратори прозора
маркети то електронного каталогів це ми
як я вже казав державна установа
професійні закупівлі
наша зона відповідальності - це адміні
формування товарів категорії широкого
вжитку
це
електроенергія
нафтопродукти природні газ
продукти харчування
офісне
приладдя устаткування меблі побутова
техніка будівельні категорії
багато-багато інших товарів категорій
широкого вжитку є адміністратор
державного підприємства медичні
закупівлі України вони
адміністрають
зрозуміли мабуть товари медичного
напрямку Тобто це лікарський засоби по
вся форматологія
медичне обладнання і навіть вже і
медичний транспорт також
нещодавно до нас доєдналась третя тзо
Яка також стала адміністратором
електронних каталогів да це державне
підприємство український спеціальні
системи
це філія
державного спецзв'язку
тому вони відповідно будуть
адмініструвати категорії
it напрямку Тобто це комп'ютерне
обладнання з сервера програмне
забезпечення і інші категорії
ті
функціоналу Да що таке адміністратори в
Маркеті наша головна роль - це в першу
чергу відбір і кваліфікація
постачальників до відповідних категорій
і безпосередньо це наповнення
електронного каталогу да відповідно
асортиментом категорій товарів і профілі
ну саме це ми як адміністратори і
займаємося Ну і третя так би мовити
група
стейкволдерів та цієї екосистеми це
тендерні майданчики Я сподіваюсь ну всі
точно знаєте і маєте робочі ваші
кабінети
набуті на якомусь із тендерних
майданчиків тут представлені ну найбільш
популярні
головна роль майданчиків в даній
екосистемі - це
створення відповідного інтерфейсу Да і
надання доступу до системи в принципі до
системи prozorro і до прозорої Маркету
через ваші робочі кабінети
для як для замовників так і для
постачальників відразу хочу акцентувати
увагу вашу про те що над кожним
майданчику інтерфейс відповідно
відповідний Він має свої особливості і
може відрізнятися там один від іншого
тому
бувають
скарги і або якісь зауваження з боку
замовників в наш адресу
Ну який зачасту Ну не відноситься до
нашої
відповідальності в принципі є
недоопрацюванням з боку деяких тендерних
майданчиків тому ідеальному варіанті Да
ми рекомендуємо вам мати робочі кабінети
на декількох
декількох тендерних майданчиків які в
принципі це для замовників абсолютно
безкоштовна історія якщо казати про
нормативним врегулювання
електронних каталогів то на сьогоднішній
день
основний нормативний документ який
регулює
дію самого електронного каталогу це
постанова Кабінету Міністрів 822 яка в
принципі визначає бізнес-процес роботи з
електронними каталогами тому якщо є
Точніше так якщо хтось ще не знайомий з
цим
всі постанови Да мы там рекомендуємо
обов'язково з нею познайомитись також
Слід зазначити що є постанова 1178 яка
фактично
ну надала суттєвий поштовх
суттєвий поштовх для розвитку
електронних каталогів знаєте да
постанова 11,78 вона фактично визначає
особливості закупівельного періоду
воєнного стану саме цієї постановою як
казала пані Тетяна на початку да саме
цієї постановою закупівля товарів через
електронний каталог
стала одним із двох основних
конкурентних способів закупівлі для
державних замовників Тобто ви можете
купувати товари або тільки або через
відкриті торгів з особливостями або
[музика]
через прозора марки це перший момент
другий момент саме постановою 1178
були зняті будь-які вартісні вартісні
обмеження використання прозоро Маркету
да тому що
до цього прозора марки максимально
сума яка була доступна для закупівель
prozorrowardkiss 200 000 грн наразі
замовники не мають взагалі ніяких
вартісних обмежень і тому це в принципі
є одним із
таких
серйозних поштовх і да для послужила для
розвитку прозора Маркету Да і починаючи
саме з прийняттям цієї постанови ми
бачимо як
суттєво
зросло використання
prozorro Маркету ми бачимо
дуже багато вже кейсів закупівельних де
замовники купують на десятки мільйонів
гривень тому в принципі я ще раз фокусую
на увагу на тому що
прозора маркет є повноцінним
інструментом для закупівлі товарів для
державних замовників
будь-які да починаючи там
самих маленьких і закінчуючих
закінчуючим великими державними
компаніями
саме Міністерство економіки дуже цьому
питанні також допомагає дав розвитку
електронних каталогів максимально
підтримує нас І взагалі цей процес тому
ми тут показуємо Да і було таке
рекомендоване листя з боку Міністерства
економіки на всі органи державної влади
і на місцевій На центральній на будь-які
установи там організації про те що
прозора маркет є повноцінним там
закупівельним інструментом для закупівлі
товарів саме товарів ще раз акцентую
увагу тому що послух на сьогоднішній
день в каталозі не представлена ми над
цим там думаємо можливо
середньостроковій перспективі там в
якості пілота ми спробуємо да додати
деякі типові послуги на
щоб вони стали доступні для замовників у
електронному каталозі наразі послуг
немає представлені товари
причому товари які як ви розумієте це
все ж таки більш
стандартизовані товари більш типові
товари які
купуються як ми за якими мають потребу
більша частина замовників в Україні тому
Ну в каталозі важко знайти якісь товари
унікальні які там за якими мають потреби
окремі замовники це все ж таки мова йде
про стандартизацію і протиповіт
тобто зараз якщо розімувати тобто зараз
прозора маркет перетворився вже в такий
великий повноцінний
державний
тобто починалося це все історія да як я
казав в 19-му році як невеличкі пілотний
проект для закупівель там типових
товарів на невеликі Суми
там більш в мірі там офісне якесь
устаткування чи приладдя Да там якісь
ноутбуки то зараз це вже повноцінний
конкурентний великий такий спосіб
закупівлі це повноцінний продукт
в якому вже зараз да за період існування
прозора Маркету додана більше ніж 800
категорій різних товарів самих товарів
там більш ніж вже представлена 80 тисяч
всіма нами адміністраторами створена
більше ніж 7,5 тисяч стандартизованих
технічних завдань і далі ми трошки
пояснимо що таке технічні завдання або
ще як профіль на товари як прийнято його
називати
Ну і слід зауважте Я вже казав Да що
одна із головних ролей адміністратора -
це відбір і кваліфікація постачальників
тобто зараз вже
кваліфікована до прозора Маркету більш
ніж 4000
постачальників відповідно за різними
категоріями
далі я пропоную передати слово своєму
колезі це Дмитро Соловей начальник
відділу електронних каталогів професійні
закупівлі він вам розкаже і покаже На
конкретних цифрах На конкретних
прикладах кесах покаже безпосередньо як
працює prozorro Market який результат ми
маємо роботи станом на сьогодні Які
переваги прозоро марки
надає
користувачам тому
прошу далі Дмитро продовжити дякую
Дуже дякую Євгене Дуже дякую пані Тетяні
за дійсно важливі вступні слова я
пропоную зараз продовжити з нагадування
всім колегам стосовно того що дійсно
прозора маркет розпочав свою роботу ще у
2019 році хто довший час закупівлях
працює ми знаємо що і заклади
професійно-технічної освіти і раніше
користувалися прозора Маркетом Спочатку
це був інструмент який виступав аналогом
процедури звітування тобто на початку в
рамках пілотного проекту замовники
купували
використовували прозоро марка для того
щоб знайти постачальника якогось
типового товару паперу наприклад або
пального на суми до 50 гривень до 50
тисяч гривень коли в принципі і вони
могли би звітувати
вже тоді інструмент показав свою
успішність і актуальність популярність
серед замовників Тому вже там 21-му році
в 2021 році навесні розширився
функціонал з'явився інструмент
конкурентної процедури закупівлі Це
запит цінових пропозицій коли вже не
просто замовник обирав постачальника а
оголошував запит на який реагували
постачальники пропонували свої ціни Ну і
система автоматично визначала переможцем
Ця процедура тоді була аналогом
спрощеної процедури закупівлі мала
обмеження в 200 000 грн і насправді
показувало себе ефективно і якісно тому
ми вже тоді чули запити від замовників
що дуже гарно було якби можна було
використовувати запит цінових пропозицій
у прозоро маркет і як аналог відкритим
торгам Ну і це сталося восени Минулого
року коли власне Кабінет Міністрів
України вносив особливості щодо
публічних закупі це період дії воєнного
стану своєю постановою 11,78 так як під
час війни повноцінної дуже важливо
закривати всі потреби які виникають
швидко і ефективно купувати конкурентно
що особливо важливо то було прийнято
рішення ввести електронний каталог з
аромаркет і записи нових пропозицій як
власне повноцінний аналог процедури
відкритих торгів Яка теж свої зміни
були в неї внесені на відповідно терміни
трохи відкритих торгів теж зменшилися Ну
як тільки ці процедури стали рівноцінні
між собою для використання замовниками
щодо закупівлі товарів то насправді
результати не забарилися вже У листопаді
минулого року на перший місяць після
повноцінної такої легітимації запиту
цінових пропозицій як інструменту
закупівлі без обмежень сума витрачених
коштів замовниками у прозоро як склала
більше четверті мільярду гривень Ну а
вже в грудні традиційно один з
найактивніших закупівельних місяців
Минулого року
сума витрачених коштів замовниками
упризор маркет наближалася до одного
мільярду гривень перевищувала 800
мільйонів гривень ця тенденція вона
продовжує цей Протягом цього року 2023
Звісно що з поправкою на сезонність тому
що ну традиційно наприклад зараз кінець
весни літо замовники менше коштів
витрачають але не означає що менше
закупівель проводять тому що зараз
постійно докуповуються продукти
харчування постійно докуповується нафта
дистиляти це талони на бензин це бензин
наливом наприклад для генераторів
постійно докуповується канцелярія є
потреба оновлювати і проводити якісь
точковий ремонт тобто докуповувати
Будівельні матеріали тому закупівлі
відбувається і ми навіть фіксуємо
найкращий показники за весь рік у травні
цього року по використанню замовниками
прозора марки Якщо говорити про
конкретні результати
якісні то можна сказати про те що обсяг
закупівель у прозоромаркет вже
наближається до 5 млрд грн власне ми
очікуємо що вже у червні цього року
тобто в цьому місяці сума продажів у
прозоро маркет перевищить 5 млрд грн Ну
а до кінця року перевищать 10 мільярдів
гривень судячи з тих тенденцій ми
очікуємо саме такі показники на цей час
замовники з постачальниками
використовуючи інструмент prozorro
Market уклали вже понад 50 тисяч угод Ну
а власне скористалося тобто проводили
закупівлі більше 7 тисяч замовників якщо
порівнювати цю кількість замовників з
тією кількістю яка в принципі протягом
роботи існування прозоромаркет проводила
конкурентні закупівлі товарів у системі
prozorro то ми розуміємо що вже понад
всіх замовників користувалися прозоро
маркет Це доволі гарний показник у нас
зараз хороші темпи зростання Але разом з
тим ми розуміємо що все означає що там
близько
75%, ще не користувалися тому ми не лише
працюємо над тим щоб вдосконалювати
продукт структурно технічно нормативного
разом з колегами з державного
підприємства прозоро разом з колегами з
Міністерства економіки про Що пані
Тетяна на початку сказала а й проводимо
подібні заходи для того щоб
популяризувати інструмент доносити його
цінність зручність для замовника
доносити ті показники економії яких
вдається досягти Ну і власне залучати в
собі ще і більше замовників до його
використання серед постачальників Євген
вже сказав про те що більше чотирьох
тисяч постачальників пройшли
кваліфікацію були перевірені
адміністраторами і отримали
дозвіл на участь у закупівлях які замо
оголошують через прозоромаркет через
записи нових пропозицій кількість
постачальників які вже мають підписані
договори з замовниками наближається до
двох тисяч постачальників Тобто майже
кожен другий серед тих хто прийшов
кваліфікацію вже не просто бере участь а
вже має конкретний досвід підписаних
договорів і таким чином є досвідченим
постачальником який розуміє як прозора
маркет працює далі хотілося трохи
детальніше зупинитися розповісти що ж
власне можна закуповувати у прозоро
маркет в першу чергу ми зараз
проговоримо про ті категорії яка які
наша організація адмініструє але
справедливості ради заради Варто сказати
що це не лише тому що ми їх
адмініструємо а тому що це дійсно ті
категорії які складають більше 90%
закупівель у прозоро маркет як у
грошовому вимірі так і в кількостіному
вимірі так і вимірі замовників які
користуються тому що це категорії які є
найважливішими і найпопулярнішими серед
замовників в тому числі Саме ці
категорії вони є пріоритетними згідно
постанови Кабінету Міністрів 590 щодо
фінансування з держбюджету щодо
проплатплати з ночейством Тому це ті
категорії на яких ми зараз активно свою
увагу фокусуємо в першу чергу це
напрямок і кластер енергетичних
категорій це електроенергія - це
категорія газового палива це категорії
пального бензин дизель скраплений газ це
категорії твердого палива тобто вугілля
деревні пелети палети із залупиння це
деревина і всі інші категорії які
відносяться до енергетичної групи їх
всіх зручно і
Перепрошую зручно і швидко можна
закупити з використанням prozorro Market
конкурентно використовуючи запит цінових
пропозицій ну це дійсно ті категорії без
яких ті ж заклади професійно-технічної
освіти без забезпечення електричної
енергії без забезпечення газовим паливом
не можуть виконувати свої функції і
власне приймати приймати людей які
навчаються
другий важливий напрямок - це категорії
продуктів харчування тому що як не може
держава існувати без забезпечення
енергетикою так само і люди які ключові
функції виконують на різних об'єктах в
різних установах вони не можуть існувати
без забезпечення харчуванням ми зі свого
боку в тому числі разом з колегами з
Міністерства освіти науки України з
колегами з Міністерства охорони здоров'я
приймаємо активну участь у реформі
шкільного харчування ця реформа вона
відбувається під патронатом підтримки
першої леді України Олени зеленської а
власне в рамках цієї реформи саме
прозора маркет визначений як ключовий
інструмент який варто розвивати і через
який рекомендуються закладам шкільної
освіти здійснювати закупівлі харчування
але важливо для всіх замовників в
Україні в тому числі для присутніх
сьогодні це те що в рамках роботи було
напрацьовано меню команду Євгена
клопотенка яке наші фахівці нашої
установи розібрали на категорії Вийшло
майже 200 категорій продуктів харчування
Ну і до кожної з категорій ми
підготували технічні специфікації як
казали Мої колеги на початку у prozorro
Market використовується стандартизовані
технічні завдання які ви просто обираєте
з переліку і на них оголошуєте свої
запити це нових пропозицій тобто
проводити тендери всі категорії ми
розібрали на такі специфікації тому всі
продукти харчування
для приготування страв із цього меню
можна купити у прозоро маркет Ну а в
подальшому ми проаналізували закупівлі
інших замовників і зрозуміли що цей
перелік категорій і цей перелік
специфікації він покриває повністю
потреби будь-яких замовників по
території України тому зараз цими
напрацюваннями користуються абсолютно
всі у нас крім шкіл крім дитячих
садочків крім закладів профтех освіти в
тому числі зараз закуповують такі великі
замовники продукти харчування як
Укрнафта які з цього року приводять свої
закупівлі у прозоро вони власне для
своїх їдалень для забезпечення своїх
працівників молоком
використовують прозоро маркет до
прикладу в травні вони закупили молока
провели 4 закупівлі і закупили молока на
суму Понад 12 мільйонів гривень хто
слідкує за новинами за закупівельними
новинами то знає про те що процес
прозоро маркет активно використовують
для своїх закупівель заклади для
відбування покарань осуджених людей
тобто пенітетна служба Міністерства
Юстиції власне про це активно Міністр
юстиції комунікує вони як
децентралізовані тобто на місцях
закупівлі так і централізовані з
генеральною дирекцією Міністерство
освіти проводять закупівлі це різні
закупівлі деякі на десятки тисяч гривень
деякі на мільйони до прикладу вони
провели
найдорожчу закупівлю цукру в принципі в
історії публічних закупівель України
купували цукру на 12 мільйонів гривень
робили це саме через прозоро маркет
через запит ці нових пропозицій тому
самі різні запити і будь-які категорії
продуктів харчування можна закривати
потребу в них саме використовуючи
прозора маркет і використовуючи запит ці
нових пропозицій третій такий важливий
напрямок яким ми займаємось це офісне
обладнання офісного устаткування з цих
категорій в принципі розпочинався
прозора маркет вони були першими які
з'явилися у марке-плейсі ну і власне це
тільки категорії які замовники постійно
докуповують тому що всі постійно купують
папір офісний всі постійно докуповують
олівці ручки інша канцелярське приладдя
у нас Сотні І вже наближається до тисячі
кількість кваліфікованих постачальників
за цими категоріями тому Звісно що цей
напрямок теж швидко зручно можна
купувати У прозоро марки ми зі свого
боку адміністраємо і інші категорії які
зараз через
відповідну пріоритети по закриттю потреб
обмеження бюджету менше замовників
купують але вони теж важливі Ми
займаємося напрямком меблів займаємось
напрямком текстилю тобто
наволочки простирадла
підковдри це все теж можна купити у
прозоро маркет можна закуповувати
побутову хімію можна враховувати
будівельні товари про них і про плани
розвитку я детальніше окремо скажу Ну і
хто теж за новинами слідкує то зараз
якраз теж спільно з колегами з
Міністерства освіти науки ми працюємо і
вже оголошується закупівлі була прийнята
постанова 418 Кабінету Міністрів України
щодо надання субвенції з держбюджету до
місцевих бюджетів для закупівлі
транспорту тобто шкільних автобусів Ну і
постановою визначено що закупівлі
відбуватимуть це саме з використанням
запиту цінових пропозицій у прозора
маркет Тому ці кошти субвенції
обласній територіальні громади будуть
витрачати саме шляхом запиту цінових
пропозицій Ну і вже оголошується
закупівлі в нас лише за вчора чотири
закупівлі оголосили дехто купує по
одному автобусу поки а деякі замовники
вже оголосили закупівлі дороговартісні
на очікувану вартість у 50-60 мільйонів
гривень коли купують
десятки автобусів наші колеги з інших
цзо адмініструють свої напрямки колеги з
державного підприємства українські
спеціальні системи комп'ютерний напрямок
які він вже сказав колеги з медичним
закупівель України напрямок ліків
лікарських засобів медичного обладнання
з транспорту також швидкі можна
закуповувати автомобіль швидкої медичної
допомоги різних типів у прозоро маркет
тому асортимент категорії яких можна
купити зараз у prozorro Market він
доволі високий
далі давайте про переваги прозора
маркети спочатку коротко а потім на
ключових зупинимось детальніше серед
основних переваг для замовників по
використанню цього інструменту це
зручність тому що як я вже почав
розказувати на товари для використання
замовниками вже підготовлено і
стандартизовано технічне завдання
фахівцями саме цзо закупівлі з
використанням prozorro Market закупівлі
з використанням запиту цінових
пропозицій вони конкурентні і економні
ці метрики і показники за цими
параметрами вдвічі краще а інколи і
втричі краще ніж показники на відкритих
торгах з особливостями які зараз є
аналогом використання prozorro Market це
закупівлі швидкі тому що можна провести
запит си нових пропозицій конкурентну
процедури навіть за 3-4 дні в середньому
лише 10 днів на те щоб провести запит ці
нових пропозиції замовники витрачають що
значно менше ніж у випадку відкритих
торгі
Ну і дуже важливо для всіх замовників це
безпечність використання тому що на
відміну від відкритих торгів з
особливостями по використанню
прозоромаркет відповідальність за
підготовку технічного завдання
відповідальність за кваліфікацію
постачальників несуть адміністратори
тобто наша установа Якщо говорити про
товари широкого вжитку інші
адміністратори Якщо говорити про їх
напрямки тому замовники можуть безпечно
купувати закупівлі у прозоро маркет і
шляхом запиту цінових пропозицій
конкурентні закупівлі вони не підпадають
під оскарження в антимонопольному
комітеті України за рахунок того що
кваліфікацію і підготовку технічних
завдань проводять фахівці цзу не
підпадають під моніторинги
держаудисслужби тому для замовників
використання цього інструменту є так
само безпечним прозорим і зручним тому
що закупівлі не будуть не будуть
затримані і не будуть оскаржені
замовники яких хочуть найефективні
купувати можуть сміливо і безпечно
купувати У прозорому
детальніше давайте по ключових перевагах
обговоримо і зупинимося щодо зручності і
стандартизованості то дійсно до кожної з
категорій у prozorro Market наші
спеціалісти розробили набір
характеристик які мають відповідати
товари що входять до цієї категорії Ну і
крім того що було напрацьовано набір і
конкретний перелік характеристик які ми
описується кожна категорія було
напрацьовано ще і значення цих
характеристик до кожної з них для того
щоб можна було підготувати в рамках цієї
матриці характеристик стандартизовані
технічні завдання Ну і власне
використовувати замовниками під час
проведення закупівлі Таким чином коли ви
проводите закупівлю через записи нових
пропозицій у прозоромаркет то закупівля
ваша розпочинається не з того що ви
готуєте паперові версії технічного
завдання і Готу тендерна документацію як
у відкритих торгах коли проводите запит
ці нових пропозицій у prozorro Market ви
просто Заходите в свій кабінет на
електронному майданчику переходити в
інтерфейс прозоро маркет і там далі з
електронних полів вже обираєте ті
характеристики і специфікацію за якою
будете проводити свою закупівлю таким
чином це і зручно все відбувається в
системі все відбувається прозоро і
відповідно стандартизовано і ви не
витрачаєте до того ж свій час зараз
ще наявна можливість для замовників
додавати власний проект договору для
того щоб постачальники могли
ознайомитися з усіма умовами поставки
крім того що вони ознайомлюються з
технічним завданням за яким ви
оголошуєте закупівлю з частотою
регулярністю таких поставок особливо
якщо мова йде про продукти харчування до
прикладу які регулярно постачаються Ну і
власне сформувати свою цінову пропозицію
Максима якісної максимально коректно
також з нашими фахівцями нашими
уповноваженими особами нашими юристами
було напрацьовано проекти рекомендованих
договорів від централізованих
закупівельних організацій нашу установою
було підготовлено такі проекти договорів
для закупівлі пального для закупівлі
продуктів харчування і стандартизований
проект договору для закупівлі типових
товарів тому бажаючи можуть зайти на наш
сайт ознайомитися з проектами цих
договорів Можливо почеркнути щось для
використання у своїх договорах також в
проекти договорів розміщені на сайтах
інших тзо відповідно до їх напрямку і
так само вони розміщені на порталі
прозоро інфобокс там їх теж можна зайти
Ну і крім цього ми ще з останніх новин
додали проект договору для закупівлі
шкільних автобусів які замовники які
проводять ці закупівлі теж рекомендуємо
ознайомлюватися
і нам замовникам не потрібно витрачати
час на підготовку тендерної документації
коли вони використовують прозоромаркет
навіть у випадку якщо це конкурентна
закупівля на сотні тисяч гривень чи на
мільйони гривень навіть у цьому випадку
не потрібно витрачати час і не потрібно
готувати документи все відбувається
безпосередньо у системі prozorro
наступна перевага яку хотілось
детальніше обговорити це конкуренція
тому що власної постанови Кабміну 1178
Я перепрошую в когось мікрофон
ввімкнений будуть якщо відключите бо
шумить Дуже дякую
постанова Кабінету Міністрів 11.78 була
прийнята саме для того щоб повернути
конкуренцію в закупівлі тому що
конкуренція Вона потрібна для довіри від
міжнародної спільноти наших міжнародних
партнерів які значною мірою допомагають
фінансову Україні боротися з агресором
Ну і конкуренція вона є драйвером І
власне економією бюджетних коштів про що
далі ми скажемо і самого прозорому
маркет зараз здається досягати найкращих
показників тому що середня конкуренція
під час використання замовником
процедури запиту цінових пропозицій у
прозоро маркет складає 4 учасники на
тендер коли як на відкритих торгах з
особливостями лише два учасники на
тендер це свіжі дані квітня цього року
відповідно
двічі більше учасників приходять на ваші
закупівлі за рахунок кваліфікації
постачальників насправді рівень
конкуренції у запитах цінових пропозицій
постійно зростає ми бачимо динаміку на
жовтий Минулого року до прийняття
постанови 11,78 конкуренція на запитах
цінових пропозиції відкритих торах була
співставною Але зараз все нові і нові
постачальники долучаються проходять
кваліфікацію працюють у прозоро маркет
Ну і таким чином Вони беруть участь
закупівлях конкуренція підвищується за
рахунок залучення нових постачальників
кваліфікації нових постачальників ми
очікуємо і ставимо собі такі амбітні
плани Що до кінця цього року підвищити
середню конкуренцію на запитах цінових
пропозицій і до 5 учасників на тендер і
вище Ну і власне конкуренція на
закупівлях вона не є самоціллю а
очевидно що конкуренція Вона дозволяє
замовникам забезпечувати кращі показники
економії від очікуваної вартості
дозволяє заощаджувати державні кошти
заощаджувати кошти підприємств Ну і
власне медіана економії на запитах
цінових пропозицій з використанням
prozorro Market Вона складає у квітні
13%. якщо порівнювати це з медіаною
економії на відкритих торах з
особливостями то там цей показник лише
4%. Таким чином зрозуміло що економія на
запитах цінових пропозицію у прозоро
маркет більш ніж у тричі вища Таким
чином більш ніж утричі можна більше
економію отримати більше державних
коштів заощадити що я дуже важливо Ну і
так само як я сказав про показники
конкуренції ми бачимо що показники
економії яку вдається замовником
досягати вони корелюють з кількістю
кваліфікованих постачальників з
конкуренцією тому ми очікуємо що
тенденція буде так і далі на зростання
кількості постачальників а це означає що
нам в подальшому вдаватиметься
втримувати або навіть покращувати
показник економіки які замовники
досягають використовуючи використовуючи
наш інструмент
далі хотілося сказати ще про швидкість
трохи Детальніше проговорити я вже
сказав про те що більш ніж удвічі швидше
проведення запиту цінових пропозицій для
замовників в середньому лише 10 днів від
моменту коли замовник у своєму кабінеті
натискає на кнопку оголосити закупівлю
до моменту коли замовник власне вже має
підписаний договір з постачальником
завершує закупівлю у системі Ну і
публікує договір у системі варто також
зауважити що крім того що фактично час
менший як я вже на початку написав Коли
я говорив про зручність ваша закупівля з
використанням прозора Маркету Вона
починається безпосередньо у системі у
момент оголошення тоді коли як під час
відкритих торгів насправді терміни
навіть вище від 23 днів тому що вище
якийсь час в залежності від складності
категорії залежностей від кількості
позицій яку купуєте А ви використовуєте
на підготовку документації які у цих 23
днях не враховані таким чином можна
сказати що навіть майже втричі закупівлі
через записи нових пропозицій швидше ніж
відкриті торги що особливо важливо якщо
ви щось докуповуєте якщо закриваєте
якусь терміново потребу саме з
використанням прозора маркети Можна це
зробити найшвидше Ну і варто ще сказати
що закупівлі не підпадають під
оскарження і моніторинги під оскарження
в антимонопольному моніторингу дасу Тому
що Тому з цих причин також не можуть
бути
продовжені затримані Ну і таким чином 10
днів Це реальний чистий час середній час
на проведення процедури запиту цінових
пропозицій замовник витрачає мінімум
часу на оголошення закупівлі Ну і 100%
економить час на адмініструванні цієї
закупівлі тому що не повертається до
розгляду питань від постачальників не
проводить кваліфікацію фактично коли ми
перейдемо до обговорення алгоритму
проведення запиту Це нових пропозицій
стане зрозуміло що лише оголошує
закупівлю додає проект договір обираю
специфікацію І власне підписує договір
інших кроків фактично замовник у системі
і не виконує повноважена особа зменшує
навантаження
на Проведення таких закупівель щодо
ефективності то Варто сказати що
закупівлі через прозоро маркет - це
ефективно
78% Запитів цінових пропозицій і вони
стосується підписанням договору з
першого разу Після оголошення якщо
порівнювати це з відкритими торгами то
там знов таки показник нижчий там це
лише
64%, тобто менше ніж 2/3 завершується
підписанням договору особливо
критична і наглядна різниця навіть вища
за середню на закупівлях такого
важливого предмету в закупівлі як пальне
тому що в цій категорії успішні Запитів
цінових пропозицій більше
80%, А на відкритих торгах лише 62 Ну і
таким чином замовники які купують пальне
вони значно вищою вірогідністю отримують
постачальника і отримують постачання
товару швидше якщо
використовуватимуть саме прозора марки А
коли ми згадаємо ще й попередній слайд І
на те що на відкритих торгах не
успішність може виявитися лише через там
три тижні то стає очевидно і не дивно що
більшість замо вників зараз
використовують саме інструмент запиту
цінових пропозицій і він стає і все
більш більш популярним в тому числі для
закупівель пального
продовжуємо далі говорити про
безпечність тому що розумію що для
замовників безпека проведення закупівель
це один з ключових параметрів
Варто сказати що постачальники до
прозорого Маркету як я вже сказав
кваліфіковані за кваліфікацією
постачальників відповідаємо ми
централізовані закупівельні організації
Таким чином замовнику не потрібно
постачальників шукати якщо це якась
специфічна потреба або по розташуванню
замовника або поочікуваний вартості якщо
там невеликий бюджет на закупівлю Ну і
замовників не потрібно перевіряти не
потрібно проводити кваліфікаційну
перевірку всю цю роботу виконують наші
фахівці коли вони власне акредитують
кваліфікують і допускають постачальників
до участі у подальших закупівлях через
prozorro Market Так як ми цю роботу
виконуємо Беремо на для себе і
кваліфікацію і підготовку технічних
завдань той за власник кваліфікацією
відповідаємо ми відповідають
централізовані закупівельні організації
це убезпечує замовників від оскарження
як я вже сказав від моніторингів що
значно значно полегшує замовникам життя
також адміністратори централізовані
закупівельні організації ми слідкуємо за
порушеннями постачальників
попри те навіть що ви побачили на
попередньому слайді що ефективність
успішність закупівель з використанням
запиту цінових пропозицій вона значно
вища ніж у відкритих торгах і більшість
закупівель завершується вдало але маючи
там понад 4000 кваліфікованих
постачальників зрозуміло що завжди
знайдеться хтось Хто захоче порушувати
правила визначення постановою Кабміну
822 для того щоб впливати на таких
постачальників Ну по-перше нам Кабмін з
цією по спробую не дав можливість
попереджувати їх про порушення
обмежувати постачальникам які порушують
правила доступ і до подальших закупівель
у прозоромаркет ця проблема не є
системною тому що за весь час роботи
прозоромаркет лише 4
постачальники 4 учасники отримали
обмеження і були виключені з переліку
постачальників прозоромаркет але важливо
що у замовника є можливість у випадку
порушення постачальником правил
поскаржитися на постачальника тому всім
хто користується варто це пам'ятати Ну і
випадку у випадку виникнення якоїсь
такої ситуації обов'язково це робити це
можна зробити через наш сайт наш той
організації через сайти інших тзо також
це можна зробити через ваш кабінет на
майданчику На порушення постачальників
Ми також реагуємо щодо кваліфікації у
прозоро маркет розкажу коротенько як
саме ми її переходимо власне
кваліфікуючи постачальників до прозора
маркети ми перевіряємо їх досвід
кваліфікуємо перевіряючи досвід
відповідності за категоріями що входять
до четвертого знаку
класифікатора
ДК 021.2015 року відповідно якщо
постачальник хоче кваліфікуватися до
прозорого Маркету за кількома напрямками
то він окремо підтверджує досвід
постачання товарів за кожним з напрямків
Коли проходить кваліфікацію Ну і крім
того що постачальник крім того що
постачальник підтверджує свій досвід так
само наші фахівці наші уповноважені
особи виконують перевірку згідно
постанови Кабміну 822
причини відхилення заявки постачальника
на кваліфікацію у прозоромаркет вони
аналогічні причинам відхилення заявки і
пропозиції постача у закупівлю згідно
закону Згідно статті 17 тому перевірка
на доброчесність постачальників у
prozorro Market вона також виконується
ну власне це є дозволяє замовникам
спокійно без додаткових перевірок
проводити свої закупівлі у тих
постачальників які наші фахівці вже
кваліфікували
далі хотілося проговорити про
принципи функціонування прозоро маркет
як саме електронний каталог працює у нас
досі залишається можливість яка була на
самому початку використовувати прозоро
маркет як аналог звітування зараз поріг
по потребі річній за кодом класифікатора
за четвертим знаком для замовників на
рік це 100 тисяч гривень Тож у випадку
якщо ви маєте таку потребу за яку ми з
предметом закупівлі ви можете
використовувати прозоро маркет як
звичайний онлайн-маркет place як умо в
розетку чи як Амазон інші приклади
prom.ua обрати товар який хочете
закупити обрати постачальника в якого
будете це робити покласти у кошик
замовити я каналу звітування в прозоро
марка для таких потреб можна
використовувати Але разом з тим у нас є
можливість яку зараз більшість
замовників використовують це інструмент
запиту цінових пропозицій які
обов'язково використовувати замовникам
на Суми від 100 тисяч гривень це власне
процедура аналоги відкритих торгів яка
дозволяє швидко знайти найкращу ціну на
характеристики товару Як сьогодні вже
було сказано у неї зараз немає верхньої
межі замовники проводять закупівлі на
декілька мільйонів гривень на десятки
мільйонів гривень це нормативно
дозволяється але Варто сказати що немає
і нижньої межі тому
У нас багато випадків коли замовники
проводять закупівлі на декілька тисяч
гривень на десяток тисяч гривень саме
шляхом запиту цінових пропозицій на такі
закупівлі приходить доволі багато
постачальників як конкретні приклади
надалі теж покажу розкажу Ну і
відповідно Навіть є приклади коли
замовники могли б звітуватися а вже
розуміючи як працює прозора маркет як
працює запит цінових пропозицій обирають
саме цю процедуру Ну і таким чином
максимально ефективно максимально
конкурентно витрачають державні кошти
навіть на невелику суму перед тим як
далі перейти Я не знаю чи у всіх у мене
трохи помальовано хтось напевно
розмалював презентацію Я їх зараз
перезапущу з вашого дозволу і ми
продовжимо бо трохи муляє око Чесно
кажучи
так повернулися давайте продовжувати
варто надалі сказати що
алгоритм проведення запиту цінових
пропозицій доволі простий зрозумілий але
спочатку я хотів показати як
здійснюється прямі закупівлі у прозора
маркет значить вони дуже прості вони
дійсно повноцінний аналог звітування
тому не сильно ускладнюються і не сильно
відрізняються від процедури коли ви
просто десь замовляєте товар маєте таку
нормативну можливість і купуєте
відповідно перше що робите коли напряму
проводити закупівлю це додаєте товару
кошик зазначаєте кількість товару і
робите замовлення а в цей момент
чернетка звіту формується автоматично Ну
і далі у постачальника в якого ви робите
замовлення є два робочих дні на те щоб
підтвердити його у випадку прямого
замовлення ви у одного постачальника
можете декілька предметів закупівлі
додати в кошик і таким чином провести цю
закупівлю не на один якийсь товар а якщо
це до прикладу код 30-19 то Таким чином
закупити цілий набір канцелярії Ну і
після того як вже ви підписали договір
ви просто завершуєте процедуру і
завершуєте
публікуйте звіт в електронній системі
закупівель це дуже просто тобто
абсолютно нічим не ускладнено і не
відрізняється від класичної процедури
звітування яку ви виконуєте за випадком
того що ви не позасистемою А у системі
знаходити постачальника і обираєте в
цьому випадку ви обираєте постачальника
або виходячи з своїх міркувань так як це
робите І у звітування тобто обираєте ту
ціну того постачальника цінову
пропозицію якого вважаєте найкращою це
ваше право щодо запиту цінових
пропозицій тут алго бачимо трохи довший
але не значно насправді складніший Ну а
порівнюючи з відкритими торгами то
значно значно спрощений коли проводити
запит цінових пропозицій Перше що ви
робите це власне обираєте специфікацію
яка розміщена у прозоро Маркеті і
оголошуєте свій запит у прозоромаркет
специфікації називаються профілями Ну і
в рамках одного cpv коду ви можете
декілька профілів додати до своєї своєї
закупівлі відповідно або в декількох
категоріях або навіть в одній категорії
якщо одночасно купуєте до прикладу і
бензин 92 і бензин а-95 можете
специфікації на це пальне додати до
однієї закупівлі і провести але так само
можете об'єднати в цю закупівлю ще й
дизпаливо і таким чином ці три
номенклатурні позиції закуповувати одним
запитом цінових пропозицій
так само Коли оголошуєте запит ці нових
пропозицій то ви маєте можливість і ми
рекомендуємо всім замовникам
підвантажувати проект договору станом на
зараз це не є обов'язковим але Незабаром
я думаю що вже в цьому році це стане
обов'язковим під час оголошення запиту
цінових пропозицій для того щоб
постачальники могли детально
ознайомитися з усіма умовами поставки з
кількістю точок поставок Куди Вам треба
продукцію постачати з регулярністю цих
поставок ну із умовами оплати з умовами
відтермінування платежу можливо для того
щоб вони максимально якісно коректно
могли сформувати свою цінову пропозицію
так само момент коли оголошуєте запит ці
нових пропозицій ви обираєте термін
прийому пропозиції від постачальників
системою визначено що цей термін не має
бути меншим ніж два робочих дні але
рішення Прийма А ви як замовник тому
якщо ви вважаєте Що ефективніше буде
приймати пропозиції від постачальників
довший період часу то маєте таку
можливість це зробити зі свого боку ми
аналізуючи закупівлі бачимо що у прозоро
маркет під час запиту Це нових
пропозицій саме двох робочих днів
достатньо для того щоб постачальники
могли ознайомитися з вашим запитом
підготувати свої цінові пропозиції
тому що так як вони вже кваліфіковані і
все відбувається в системі шляхом
заповнення електронних полів то
відповідно вони так само лише
ознайомлюються читають Ваш проект
договору дивляться на вашу специфікацію
на кількість товару яка вам потрібна і
вписують свою ціну жодних документів
додатково вони не готують тому і таким
чином навіть за два робочих дні
встигають вивчити запит на відповідно
подати цінову пропозицію і збирається
конкуренція після того як термін прийому
пропозиції завершується відповідно про
постачальників стають видимими в системі
Ну і відповідно система автоматично
визначає переможцем того постачальника
який надав найнижчу ціну тобто найбільше
економічно вигідно цінову пропозицію
далі у сторін у замовника і
постачальника є два робочих дні на те
щоб остаточно погодити умови договору
якщо не виникає ніяких суперечностей
стосовно умов оплати умов постачання то
постачальник підтверджує свій намір
укласти договір підтверджує визнання
себе переможцем цієї закупівлі і ви
переходите до укладання договору Якщо
протягом цього обговорення З певних
причин ви з переможцям не досягли
домовленості щодо умов виконання
договору щодо умов оплати його щось не
влаштовує то він відповідно
відмовляється від наміру укласти договір
і система автоматично визначає
переможцем наступного постачальника
цінова пропозиція якого була другою
найнижчою тобто хто надав другу найбільш
економічно вигідну цінову пропозицію ну
і з переможцем у будь-якому випадку ви
укладаєте договір обмінюватись копіями
договорів на це визначено 10 робочих
днів виділено і завершуєте закупівлю
публікуючи договір у електронній системі
закупівель
резюмуючи Варто сказати і якби визначити
що для вас є лише два етапи Це
оголошення закупівлі Ну і далі
публікація договору тому що все інше
відбувається або автоматично як
визначення переможця і кваліфікація
автоматично Вона вже здалегідь була б
постачальником пройдена так і розгляд
пропозиції Так і немає відповідей на
запитання тому як я вже казав на початку
повноважена особа коли оголошує
процедуру запиту цінових пропозицій вона
витрачає на проведення такої закупівлі
значно менше часу ніж у випадку
відкритих торгів саме На самому
адмініструванні закупівлі далі давайте
проговоримо про структуру прозоромаркет
як воно на майданчиках виглядає тут я
хотів би підтримку слів які Євген на
початку сказав нагадати всім що
майданчики Вони по-різному працюють Я
думаю що хто довший час у закупівлях
працює то можливо навіть мав досвід
роботи з різними майданчиками в них
інтерфейси по-різному і в закупівлях
працюють і в тендерах ну відповідно там
особливого гострого це питання в прозоро
Маркет А постає тому хто користується
декількома майданчиками маєте можливість
обрати той майданчик який для вас є
найзручнішим найбільш там вам за якимись
принципами подобається перевірити як на
різних майданчиках це виглядає тому що
ми відповідаємо лише за наповнення а от
демонстрацію цього це вже зона
відповідальності майданчиків тим не
менше на кожному з майданчиків
відображаються кудись cpv до прикладу
Ось так вони відображаються на одному з
майданчиків Ну і власне перше що робить
замовник коли приймає рішення про
проведення запиту цінових пропозицій це
пошуком або просто очима обирає Той код
класифікатора за яким збирається
проводити закупівлю за яким запланував
проводити закупівлю
перейшовши і клікнувши на код
класифікатора далі замовник побачить ті
категорії які адміністратори Тобто цзо
ми віднесли до кожного з кодів
класифікатора крім категорії що
відноситься до цього коду cpv одразу
буде видно специфікації назви
специфікації тобто назви профілів за
якими можна здійснювати закупівлі Ну і
коли ви вже обираєте категорію яка вас
цікавить то безпосередньо в цій
категорії ви побачите товари зображення
назви
товарів ціни до цих товарів які
постачальники розмістили у прозоро
маркет відповідності до вимог які ми як
адміністратори задали до категорії Варто
сказати що ціни які постачальники тут
розміщують А це ціни для прямих
замовлень тому їх не варто вважати
остаточними ми інколи чуємо запити про
те що ці не або за високі або не завжди
відповідають дійсності це дійсно
дійсно Інколи так особливо зараз коли не
дуже стабільно взагалі Це нова ситуація
в країні і важко постачальникам
визначити ціну на товар для прямого
замовлення особливо в залежності у
випадку публічних закупівель від того як
ви будете оплачувати це замовлення куди
його треба постачати тому ми Для
зручності вже зараз рекомендуємо
використовувати всім замовникам непряме
замовлення а саме запит ці нових
пропозицій коли ціна буде не попередньо
сформована а власне постачальник буде
формувати для вас індивідуальну цінову
пропозицію і всі постачальники будуть
формувати за вашим запитом індивідуальні
цінові пропозиції враховуючи всі ті
потреби Які у вас є Таким чином І власне
до вдається досягти і кращих показників
економіки ми власне постачальники
готують пропозиції вам їх публікують
подають Таким чином створюють
конкуренцію яку легко і просто побачити
Ну і перевірити пересвідчитися в ній
далі в кожній з категорій якщо ви
перейдете в товар то далі можна
ознайомитися з характеристиками товару
детальніше побачити ближче зображення
товару Ну і цінові пропозиції продавців
для прямого замовлення Вони теж тут
розміщені можна побачити до якого
профілю до якої технічної специфікації
чи декількох технічних специфікацій які
ми підготували як адміністра секатори
відноситься конкретний товар до прикладу
от сир ви бачите що там ми перейшли в
картку сиру і далі профіль за яким буде
відбуватися закупівля куди постачальники
зможуть пропонувати в тому числі сир
який буде обрали це специфікація насирт
твердий ваговий а масова частка жиру не
менше 50%. ну і власне характеристики
цієї специфікації характеристики цього
профілю це може бути сир будь-якої форми
брусок або циліндр масова частка жиру
має складати не менше 50%. одиниці
виміру для сиру є кілограми Це сир без
додатків без горіхів без приправ без
спецій упакований має бути в плівку ну і
відповідати тим державним стандартам тим
ДСТУ яким має відповідати сир ну і
власне коли ви оголошуватимете закупівлю
то саме на ці вимоги будуть
постачальники реагувати Ну і подавати
свої цінові пропозиції разом з
конкретними актуарами з переляку товарів
розміщених в категорії система буде
автоматично перевіряти чи відповідає
конкретний товар умовно сир твердий
Звенигора Звенигородський екстра чи
відповідає цей сир тим вимогам за якими
ви проводите закупівлю якщо відповідає
то відповідно постачальнику вдасться
подати цінову пропозицію у вашу
закупівлю вказавши свою ціну ну і таким
чином як я вже казав можна не за однією
специфікацією а додавати декілька
специфікацій до вашого запиту Це нових
пропозицій одночасно проводити закупівлю
і твердого сиру 50% жирності і твердого
сиру 45% жирності і ще й додати туди
специфікацію скажімо на сир
кисломолочний тому що постачальники
кваліфіковані в рамках коду cpv і
відверто кажучи по кожному сході всі
більшість постачальників всі категорії
мають можливість поставити
тому зручно Таким чином також поєднувати
цю потребу і проводити закупівлі в
рамках декількох категорій
використовуючи декілька профілів
декілька специфікацій купувати саме
одним запитом цінових пропозицій щодо
вибір у способу закупівлі для замовників
то зараз за результатами квітня Ну і вже
за результатами травня Сьогодні в нас 2
червня вже пішов в перший літній місяць
9 з 10 закупівель у прозоромаркет
відбуваються саме шляхом запиту ці нових
пропозицій тобто відбувається
конкурентно замовники зараз проводять
такі закупівлі навіть на суми до 100
тисяч гривень тобто як я вже казав на
невеликі Суми на декілька тисяч гривень
на десяток тисяч гривень замовники
використовують саме конкурентний спосіб
закупівлі у більшості своїй на відміну
від того як це було до
прийняття постанови до активізації
активної роботи у прозоро маркет
більшості постачальників Ну і так як
зараз конкуренція підвищена то не дивно
що більшість замовників обирають саме
найефективніший на економніший
найконкурентніший спосіб використання
прозоро марки саме запиту цінових
пропозицій далі хотілося конкретні кейси
розглянути і переконатися ще раз тому
показати вам продемонструвати щоб
прозоро марки це зараз інструмент для
будь-яких потреб замовників до прикладу
ось закупівля коли замовник купував і
його потреба була закупити електричну
енергію на весь рік замовник купував
600 тисяч кіловат годин електричної
енергії цю закупівлю вдалося провести
Всього за один тиждень сім календарних
днів від моменту Оголошення До моменту
коли вже договір було опубліковано в
системі І власне завершено закупівлю
сума цього договору склала понад два
мільйони 300 тисяч гривень Ну а власне
за рахунок того що вона була проведена
ця закупівля шляхом запиту ці нових
пропозицій у прозоромаркет то
конкуренція склала аж 17 учасників Ну і
за рахунок такої високої конкуренції
замовнику вдалося на цій закупівлі
досягти економії в п'яту частину бюджету
економії в понад 20% від очікуваної
вартості що є дуже гарним показником але
це дороговартісна доволі закупівля аж на
декілька мільйонів гривень тому я хотів
ще іншу потребу інший приклад
проговорити показати це закупівля
київводоканалу коли їх потреба була
іншою терміново поповнити запаси
трудовольства а вони купували 150 банок
консервованої кукурудзи Ну і власне
могли б використати
ID процедуру звітування але вирішили
купити конкурентно і терміни проведення
закупівлі зробити теж всього 7
календарних днів Тобто один тиждень сума
договору Була доволі невеликою менше 5
тисяч гривень але навіть на таку
закупівлю на таку доволі невелику
закупівлю яку в принципі її в АТБ Можна
було б 150 банок кукурудзи Я думаю
знайти конкуренція склала у 4 учасники
аж тобто 4 постачальники виявили бажання
прийняти участь в цій закупівлі Ну а
економія склала понад третину від
бюджету замовника від бюджету
київводоканалу на цю закупівлю і склала
аж 35%. Таким чином обравши саме запит
ці нових пропозицію прозора маркет
навіть на невелику суму замовнику
вдалося значно зекономити значно
зекономити кошти купити конкурентну
прозоро ну і ще й дуже швидко Ну і стає
зрозуміло з цих прикладів це лише два
насправді їх дуже багато зараз у нас
кожного місяця тисячі закупівель у
прозора марки шляхом запитується нових
пропозицій відбуваються щодня сотні
договорів публікуються Ну і відповідно
стає зрозуміло що дійсно на будь-які
потреби можна використовувати зараз
прозоро маркет не лише для закупівлі
бензину не лише для закупівелі паперу
всі продукти харчування в тому числі
можна купувати швидко зручно і ще багато
інших категорій саме в прозоро маркет
навіть на невеликі Суми Скажімо так на
різні суми і на великі і на невеликі
Суми інструмент працює однаково гарно
щодо використання замовниками я на
початку вже казав що більше четверті
замовників вже використовують прозора
маркет дійсно останні дані квітня
показують що відсоток замовників навіть
зростає наближається вже до третини
замовників Ну і ми активно працюємо над
тим щоб на кінець року в нас вже понад
третина замовників користувалися прозоро
маркет але зараз вже непогані результати
особливо в деяких областях до прикладу у
Тернопільській області вже більше 50%
замовників це користувачі прозора
маркети теж Серед лідерів Полтавська
область місто Київ Київська область там
більше третини вже ми працюємо проводимо
заходи для того щоб інші області
підтягувались працюємо щоб залучати
нових постачальників по всій території
України на кваліфікацію Ну і працюємо
разом з колегами з Міністерства
економіки із колегами з ДП прозоро і над
нормативкою над технічними
вдосконаленнями для того щоб прозора
маркет залишився інструментами закупівлі
і після нашої Перемоги у війні став не
лише таким інструментом екстрених під
час дії постанови 11,78 ну відповідно
був закріплений в подальшому у законі
такі напрацювання і плани я так можу
попереднього анонсувати вже є Ну і
сподіваємося що замовник із областей де
зараз відбувається активні дії
знов хтось всміхнув мікрофон я буду дуже
вдячний якщо виключити де відбуваються
активні бойові дії території які зараз
тимчасово окуповані замовники з цих
регіонів також сподіваємося з будуть
використовувати прозоро маркети у
повоєнні часи далі трохи детальніше
хотілося наприкінці про наші ключові
категорії розповісти
електрична енергія - це та категорія яку
більшість замовників купує конкурентно у
прозоро маркет конкуренція на запитах
цінових пропозицій на закупівлю
електроенергії найвища у системі в
середній показник конкуренції складає в
принципі нечувані для публічних
закупівель 12 учасників на тендер крім
того що це конкурентні закупівлі для
замовників це ще й гарно можливість
почати закуповувати електричну енергію з
оплатою за формульним розрахунком тому
що така специфікація такий профіль на
закупівлю електричної енергії був
напрацьований нашими фахівцями
розміщений у прозоро маркет якщо в двох
словах казати то оформлений розрахунок
електричної енергії це спосіб оплати
коли вартість кіловат-години протягом
розрахункового періоду протягом місяця
вона прикріплюється до цінової ситуації
на ринку до ринку на добу наперед
наприклад
відповідно якщо ситуація на ринку
змінюється ціни зростають ви теж платите
більше але лише співставно і пропорційно
до зростання на ринку враховуючи лише
маржу постачальника якщо ціни на ринку
знижуються Таким чином і платите ви за
цей конкретний місяць з електричною
енергією менше не підписуючи додаткових
угод це дуже зручно це неефективніший
насправді спосіб закупівлі електричної
енергії саме таким чином ми проводимо
закупівлі для міністерств для
центральних органів виконавчої влади
тому що як сказав Євген на початку ми ще
й крім того що адміністратори ми ще є
замовником ми проводимо закупівлі і
безпосередньо самі Це той інструмент
який ми використовуємо формульний
розрахунок Ну і власне це те як
комерційний сегмент ринку закуповує як
бізнес закуповує електричну енергію На
жаль публічний сектор не так активно цим
стосується але ми зі свого боку
докладаємо всіх зусиль щоб максимально
популяризувати Цей спосіб закупівлі
електричної енергії у нас на сайті
розміщена інформація актуальність до
того як з цим користуватися тому якщо
комусь цікаво наприкінці будуть наші
контакти заохочуємо
переходити на наш сайт вивчити Це
питання У нас на Facebook багато новин
на цей рахунок Ну якщо будуть питання
щодо закупівлі електричної енергії в
тому числі за формульним розрахунком
можете нам телефонувати зв'язуватись
електронною поштою Як вам буде зручніше
ми готові до комунікації до зворотнього
зв'язку готові надавати роз'яснення Ну
як результат було укладено на закупівлю
електроенергії вже більше двох тисяч 200
договорів а сума цих договорів вже
наближається до позначки у півтора
мільярди гривень Ну і ми очікуємо що на
кінець цього року Вона вже перевищує 3
мільярди гривень сума договорів на
закупівлю електроенергії у прозоро марки
друга важлива категорія про яку трохи
детальніше хотілося проговорити все
закупівлі пального це бензин це дизельне
паливо це скраплений газ Варто сказати
що у прозоро маркет наявна можливість
закуповувати пальне різними способами
поставки як талонами та картками так і
наливом в тому числі є можливість
декілька специфікацій різні способи
поставки об'єднати в один запит цінових
пропозицій за потреби такі закупівлі В
нас теж успішно завершуються навіть на
великі обсяги в нас є приклад коли одне
з лісогосподарств таким чином
скомбінувавши і наливи картки талони
проводили закупівлю на десятки мільйонів
гривень і навіть ця закупівля
завершилась у прозора Маркету успішно
підписанням договору Ну А загалом у
прозоро маркет зараз відбувається вже
понад 40% тендерів насправді за
результатами травня е-е позначка вже
майже у 50% пройдена ми до неї
наближаємося і сподіваємося що вже в
червні більше половини замовників більше
половини тендерів що відбуваються у
прозоро на закупівлю пального
відбуватимуться саме шляхом запиту
цінових пропозицій у прозоромаркет тому
якщо купуєте випальне то теж заохочуємо
саме використовувати цей інструмент для
закупівлі палива для закриття потреби у
паливі Варто сказати що нам моя
адміністраторам було кваліфіковано вже
більше сотні постачальників пального
це не лише лідери ринку це не лише
око-вог Авіас великий системні мережі
АЗС Ми так само Працюємо з регіональними
постачальниками для того щоб замовники з
усіх районів нашої країни з усіх
регіонів з усіх областей могли
використовуючи прозоро маркет
використовуючи запит ці нових пропозицій
купити пальне ми активно активно
долучаємо постачальників ми власне зараз
вже Близько 90% від цих гравців на ринку
пального навіть регіональних
кваліфіковані до prozorro Market Ну і ми
теж докладаємо всіх зусиль щоб вже в
цьому році повністю покрите потреби всіх
замовників всіх постачальників
кваліфікувати але навіть зараз Як бачите
більшість замовників абсолютно якісно і
швидко можуть закривати свою потребу у
пальному саме шляхом запиту цінових
пропозицій тому ще раз наголошую
долучайтеся і ви було укладено вже
більше 10 тисяч договорів на закупівлю
пального сума цих договорів вже теж
вважається до позначки півтора мільярди
гривень власне в червні ця позначка вже
буде пройдена а до кінця року ми теж
очікуємо що вже і буде подвоєно понад 3
мільярди гривень ми очікуємо що буде
сума продажів у цьому році на пальне у
прозорому про харчування я детальніше
трохи на початку розказував дійсно у нас
близько 180 категорій та специфікації до
кожної з цих категорій на продукти
харчування що покривають всі потреби
замовників розміщені в прозоромаркет
будь-які продукти харчування теж швидко
зручно ефективно можна купити
використовуючи наш інструмент знаємо що
харчування величезна кількість
замовників купують тому заохочуємо і ще
раз наголошуємо вас теж використовувати
прозоро марки для закупівлі цих потреб
це інструмент який перевірений вже понад
тисячою і сотнею замовників понад 1100
замовників вже купували продукти харчу
звичайно через електронний каталог це
якби офіційний рекомендований інструмент
в рамках реформи шкільного харчування в
тому числі за час роботи
прозора маркет було укладено на
закупівлі харчів вже більше 10 тисяч
договорів сума вже перевищує півмільярду
гривень і буде зростати і надалі ми це
вже бачимо місяць від місяця коли
десятки а то і сотні мільйонів гривень
за останні місяці витрачаються
замовниками з використанням прозоро
марки Ну і канцелярія - це те що теж Ми
як цезу купуємо для центральних органів
виконавчої влади специфікації і профілій
які використовуються у прозоро маркет
вони так само перевірені нашим досвідом
проведення централізованих закупівель як
замовника 60 найпопулярніших категорій
на канцелярію розміщені у прозоро маркет
потребу в них можна об'єднати в одну
закупівлю провести наприклад один запит
цінових пропозицій за кодом cpv30
У нас є приклади колись замовники
купували об'єднували понад 30 понад 40
навіть специфікації в один запит і
успішно проводили таку закупівлю тому
потребу повністю канцелярії вашої
організації можна теж закривати
використовуючи саме записи нових
пропозицій у прозоро Маркеті це швидко
зручно було укладено вже більше 5000
договорів на закупівлю цих категорій
товарів загальна сума цих договорів вже
більше 170 мільйонів гривень
також декілька слів хотілось сказати про
постачальників яких працюють у прозоро
маркет про постачальників яких саме наша
установа кваліфікує нами було
кваліфіковано вже понад 3700
постачальників деякі постачальники
перетинаються з тими яких кваліфікують
інші
адміністратори інші цзо можливість
долучитися до переліку кваліфікованих є
у всіх постачальників України особливо
просто зробити це
тим постачальникам проходити перевірку
які вже мають досвід продажів у прозоро
для них трохи спрощена перевірка по
досвіду ми перевіряємо ці дані
автоматично в аналітичних модулях бі
прозоро тому якщо ви працюєте з якимось
замовником який показав себе з ліпшої
сторони якого ви можете рекомендувати
можливо рекомендуєте своїм колегам
закупівельникам то Запрошуйте їх теж на
кваліфікацію до прозоро маркет Таким
чином і всім іншим допоможете підвищити
конкуренцію Ну і на ваші закупівлі у
прозоро маркет в подальшому тому що ми
очікуємо активний розвиток цього
інструменту цей постачальник теж буде
Приймати участь теж буде приходити Ну і
таким чином життя всіх в тому числі
постачальника який більше продажів буде
робити життя всіх стане якіснішим і
кращим трошки
далі про наші плани теж буквально два
слова Варто сказати зараз міністерством
економіки України нам поставлена задача
і амбітні плани щодо розвитку напрямку
будівельних товарів до кінця цього року
ми плануємо 70% від номенклатури
категорії будівельного напрямку
розмістити у прозоро маркет це більше 50
популярних категорій ми очікуємо що вже
з наступного року вони генеруватимуть
більше 7000 закупівель на рік на суму
договорів більше трьох мільярдів гривень
тому вже зараз влітку починаємо цю
роботу поступово будуть
перепрацьовуватися опрацьовуватися нові
категорії будівельних товарів тому
Слідкуйте за новинами це теж той
Напрямок в якому ми зараз будемо
приділяти значну увагу Ну відповідно це
теж ті категорії які можна буде у
прозоро маркети ефективно закуповувати
ми очікуємо що в рамках закупівель цих
буді вельних товарів тисячі
держзамовників долучиться і будуть
ефективно швидко купувати будівельні
конструкційні товари вікна двері Саме
через прозоро маркет в тому числі
нагадуємо які майданчики дають доступ до
прозоро маркет це 8 найпопулярніших
серед замовників електронних майданчиків
ми з ними на зв'язку тому до них можна
звертатися щодо роз'яснення в рамках Як
нормативки так і в рамках оголошення
запиту цінових пропозицій до прикладу
оголошення вашого запиту цінових
пропозицій якщо ви цього ще не робили Ми
рекомендуємо хто там Можливо ще не
користувався або хто не до кінця
задоволений наприклад своїм майданчиком
перевірити як працює як відображається
прозоро маркет на інших майданчиках щоб
знайти найбільш підходящі для вас саме
тому
Закликаємо використовувати прозоро марки
Закликаємо звертатися і до служби
підтримок майданчиків тому що вони
абсолютно компетентні в тому щоб вам і
роз'яснення надати відповісти на ваші
найпопулярніші питання Як щодо
нормативки так і відповідно технічні
щодо того куди натискати як оголошувати
записи нових пропозицій як
звітуватись як завершувати Договори і
так далі І так далі Ну і резюмуючи
хотілось сказати що прозоро марки - Це
дійсно зараз найефективніший інструмент
який дозволяє проводити закупівлі
стандартизованих типових товарів швидко
забезпечує найвищі показники конкуренції
забезпечує найвищі показники економії
державних коштів це інструмент безпечний
для замовників за рахунок того що
відповідальність за кваліфікацію і час
на проведення кваліфікації час на
підготовку технічних завдань власне
витрачають фахівці централізованих
закупівельних організацій Таким чином
замовники абсолютно безпечно спокійно
можуть широкий вибір потреб закривати у
прозоро маркет зараз вже сотні категорій
товарів наявні у прозорому Маркеті ми ми
і наші колеги інші адміністратори
повинно працюємо над тим щоб і технічно
покращувати користувацький досвід І
власне розширювати перелік категорій
щодо технічних і нормативних
вдосконалень то у нас на це літо амбітні
плани ми разом з колегами з Міністерства
економіки України разом з колегами з
державного підприємства прозоро ми на це
літо пряму плануємо масштабне оновлення
у прозоро марки для покращення
користувацького досвіду ну в тому числі
воно буде стосуватися можливостей
розширених замовниками щодо використання
прозоро маркет щодо уточнення
специфікації Тобто ми до певної суми до
50 тисяч гривень дамо замовникам за ті
матрицею характеристики яку ми як
адміністратори підготували уточнювати
формувати свої технічні завдання Ми дамо
замовникам можливість аргументовано у
випадку якщо постачальник після
підтвердження для себе переможцем
відмовляюся підписувати договір
відхиляти пропозицію такого
постачальника щоб не скасовуватись
закупівлю Ну і Крім того ми плануємо ще
видозмінити прямі замовлення для того
щоб успішність закупівель підвищувати
тобто переводити все на принцип запиту
цінових пропозиції очікуємо від цього
навіть зростання показників тому активно
Слідкуйте за новинами Я думаю що ті
результати яких зараз здається досягати
це ще не межа і ми докладаємо і будемо
докладати всіх зусиль для того щоб
реагувати на запити замовників на того
щоб для того щоб покращувати
користувацький досвід замовників і
відкриті до зворотнього зв'язку тому
Залишаємо наш сайт Залишаємо email
телефони Як вам зручніше буде у випадку
питання можете до нас звертатися
шукаємо наш контакт в тому числі на
Facebook там ми активно публікуємо
новини щодо закупівельної тематики так
як виступаємо замовниками і
запивальниками в тому числі проводимо
закупівлі для міністерств публікуємо там
регулярно новини щодо оновлення і
закупівель прозоро маркет щодо цікавих
кейсів тому хто користується мережею
Facebook теж рекомендуємо наш наш знайти
підписатися Це де у професійні закупівлі
можна у Фейсбуці знайти Ну і так само ми
там зараз в чат продублювали тому хто
активно користується для того щоб всі
новини актуально отримувати то
рекомендуємо підписуватися зараз Ось у
чаті останнє повідомлення Це саме
посилання на наш Facebook ну а зараз я
пропоную перейти до відповіді на
запитання
світі у замовників є я бачу тут деякі
питання вже в чаті Ось перше питання яке
бачу що стосовно презентації так
презентація буде ми звичайно що
поділимося з колегами з директорату
професійної освіти Міністерства освіти
науки України Я думаю що колеги
розшарять на всіх учасників
сьогоднішнього заходу як запис так і
самопрезентацію от якщо у когось є
запитання до речі я сподіваюсь що у нас
така можливість є ну принаймні я чув
хтось вмикав мікрофони прямо під час
презентації тому хто можливо кому
зручніше голосом задати запитання то вас
вже зараз є можливість Увімкнути
мікрофон задати питання голосом давайте
Дмитре з вашого дозволу Я спочатку
прокоментую про презентацію
Це ми щоб вас не перебивати з Євгеном
окремо Окремо списали з під час вашої
презентації Я вже її маю копію і
відповідно
поширює колегам разом із записом даного
вебінару
дорогі друзі
так само в чаті
останнє останнє повідомлення є Якщо вам
не хочеться звертатись до
навчально-методичного центру або ви
хочете мати своє особисте посилання зі
своєю особистою копією презентації то
будь ласка по завершенню вебінару
Заповніть форму за посиланням яка
вивчатику і приблизно за годину
я зможу
Відправити Відправити вам копії
думаю можна перейти до запитань
відповідей
Так я бачу запитання
Родіон задає якщо закупівля не відбулася
через ДЦП чи можна після цього робити
прямий договір зараз постановою 11,78 не
дозволяється цього робити тобто якщо у
вас не відбулася процедура запиту
цінових пропозицій ви можете або
переоголосити записи нових пропозицій
або оголосити відкриті торгів з
особливостями не можна йти у прямий
договір прямий договір можна йти лише у
випадку якщо у вас відкриті торги не
відбулися тобто якщо не відбувся запит
си нових так як це значно швидша
процедура яка в принципі може і там за
тиждень відбутися тому ви маєте
можливість у випадку там неуспішного зцп
або переоголосити зацп щось змінити в
закупівлі або оголосити відкриті торги А
у звітування йти лише тоді коли відкриті
торги були неуспішними
Ірина задає питання Скажіть будь ласка
до 100 тисяч на рік закупівля товарів по
коду ДК правильно я розумію через
prozorro Market Ірина дивіться щодо
обмеження і трешколду в 100 тисяч якщо
ваша потреба за кодом класифікатора на
рік менше 100 тисяч гривень то
відповідно ви можете або купувати поза
системою тобто
використовуватись процедуру звітування
якщо потреба за кодом ДК менша 100 000
гривень на рік або Для зручності
використовувати прозоро маркет будь-яким
чином або проводити запити ці в Нових
пропозицій щоб неактуальніші ціни
отримувати це швидко або напряму
купувати ну тобто
прозора марка під у цьому випадку як
такий опціональним додатковий інструмент
який дозволяє постачальників знаходити
які дозволяє Ну я сподіваюся що у
багатьох замовників є все-таки бажання
витрачати найефективніше кошти ваших
організацій кошти бюджетні тому
дозволяєш швидко отримати конкуренцію
зекономити гроші от А якщо ваша потреба
за кодом класифікатора річна понад 100
000 грн то ви вже зобов'язані або
користуватися саме запитом цінових
пропозицій купувати конкурентну у
прозоро маркет або використовувати
відкриті торги з особливостями Ну як ви
розумієте протягом там останньої години
я говорю Що я на стороні запиту Це нових
пропозицій я рекомендую саме цю
процедуру вам використовувати Звичайно
що якщо це товари типові товари які є в
прозоро маркет якщо це зараз у вас там
потреба в якомусь специфічному товарі
наприклад який не є типовим серед
замовників то у вас зараз лише варіант
проводити відкриті торги але ми працюємо
І у вас є до речі у будь-якого замовника
можливість через майданчики
вказати про те що товару який вам
необхідний не має поки що в прозора
Маркеті ми такі за збираємо бачимо їх ну
відверто кажучи не миттєво реагуємо тому
що нам треба проаналізувати зрозуміти
наскільки потреба умовно в якомусь
спортивному інвентарі чи іншій категорії
товарів вона є агрегованою І дійсно
потребою якою будуть користуватися
багато замовників але ви обов'язково про
це повідомляєте багато часу на це не
треба А в майбутньому це теж впливатиме
на формування наших пріоритетів по
роботі з майбутніми категоріями далі
бачу з Кривого Рогу запитання задають А
це щодо запису бачу колеги відповіли там
є рука піднята Христина Козачок можливо
Голос
будь ласка задавайте питання
пані Христина Якщо ви нас чуєте і це не
випадкова натискання то
колеги готові відповісти на ваше
запитання
ймовірно це помилково колеги щелкової
запитання будь ласка
бачу пані Людмила задає у чаті чи
можливо закупити електричну енергію
через prozorro Market для потреб
гуртожитків по тарифу для населення ну
дивіться по закупівля через прозоро
маркет вона відбувається за цінами які
формують постачальники на запит тому там
зафіксованим тарифом закуповувати не
вийде скоріш за все тому це закупівля
дійсно конкурентна на яку постачальники
пропонують свої ціни якщо мова йде про
тариф для населення то це бо за системою
здійснюється Якщо у вас є якісь
утворення чи проблема стосовно цього то
ви можете або зараз проговорити якщо
зможемо одразу відповісти відповімо або
з нами зв'язатися ми там уточнимо і я
сподіваюся що зрозуміліше стане але Поки
що виглядає що ви просто можете по цьому
тарифу мати договір з постачальником і
купувати навіть не використовуючи не
використовуючи систему prozorro
Якщо у вас є така можливість звичайно
якщо ви зобов'язані проводити через
prozorro от то ви в принципі не можете
цим тарифом скористатися
Радивилівський професійний ліцей задає
Питання якщо товар відсутній у каталозі
звертатися на майданчик чи одразу вам
наймир дякую за запитання
найкраще через майданчик тому що в нас
вже системно побудований цей процес як я
сказав на майданчиках є кнопки де
агреговано ці запити потрапляють ми
бачимо їх можемо звести однакові запити
відреагувати і одразу у нас сформується
такий перелік і контактів постачальників
замовників з якими можна буде зв'язатися
тому ви найкращі
зв'язуйтесь з вашим майданчиком і вони
вже проконсультують де Заповнити цю
форму щоб надати таку заявку
далі хтось не підписаний задає питання
Добрий день прямий договір без
використання електронної системи товару
до
розподілу важко до мільйону
тисяч гривень на безрозподілу важко
зорієнтуватися в кількості ноликів а
послуги уточніть Ну дивіться стосовно
порогів це зараз визначено постановою
11,78
можете ознайомитися з нею послуги зараз
не можна використовувати закупівлі через
прозоро маркет Як Євген на початку
сказав ми лише працюємо над цим та
плануємо розпочинати з якихось типових
послуг тому як тільки вони з'являться у
прозоро маркети ми обов'язково про це
проінформуємо тому що розуміємо Що
Потреба замовників у закупівлі послуг ну
особливо стандартизованих є послуги
різні Але в принципі якщо мова йде про
прибирання якщо мова йде про інші типові
послуги Можливо там охорона послуги з
обслуговування офісного устаткування то
ми розуміємо що ну це така така
категорія послуг яку можна було б
закуповувати через прозоро маркет тому
чекайте новин давайте не стомимося
рекламувати себе ще раз продублюємо
посилання на Facebook Підписуйтесь як
тільки з'являться послуги
проінформуємо всіх користувачів так само
так Скажіть будь ласка чи можна закупити
Оксана задає запитання Доброго дня
Оксана Скажіть будь ласка чи можна
закупити через prozorro Market
культиватор заграчисну машину та
вантажний автомобіль на жаль зараз саме
цих категорій у прозоро маркет немає
тому що ну відверто кажучи не
найтиповіші товари але ми кажу ми не
відмовляємося і не кажемо що це не
з'явиться Можливо там навіть в доволі
не найдовші терміни Можливо навіть в
цьому році тому ви обов'язково
заповнюйте заявку про те що цього товару
не знайшли і якщо Це ваша потреба якась
от яку вже треба закривати у стислі
терміни то Вам варто проводити відкриті
торгівля закупівлю цих товарів всі
замовники до речі мають можливість
скориставшись майданчиком пошук по
прозоро маркер знайти і знайти код
цікаві за яким плануєте закупівлю знайти
категорію пересвідчитися чи є вона в
Маркеті чи ні якщо немає то тоді вже йти
відкриті торги але рекомендуємо перш за
все ознайомитися з асортиментом прозоро
маркет Ну і відповідно якщо зрозумієте
що там цієї категорії товарів немає то
тоді вже переходити до відкритих торгів
А ми обов'язково повідомимо як я вже
сказав Вона зараз транспорт починає
з'являтися у прозора маркет вже є
автомобілі швидкої медичної допомоги вже
є шкільні автобуси можливо і вантажні
автомобілі теж скоро з'являться колеги
тут просять презентацію далі Дякую вам
Дякуємо вам за те що долучилися
витратили свій час задавали питання
сподіваємося що було корисно далі колеги
задають питання предмет закупівлі з
поточного ремонту визначається з
будівлями чи за адресами Дякую Ну
насправді дивіться колеги я розумію що
питання є різні і вони для вас важливі
На жаль Просто ми не є настільки
компонентними експертами щодо закупівлі
саме робіт тому що там є своя специфіка
рекомендуємо у вас є можливість у для
того щоб вас не Як то кажуть футболи то
дивіться У нас є такий гарний портал
прозоро інфобокс можливо зараз навіть
посилання теж в чат продублюємо можливо
не всі знайомі там багато корисної
інформації там наші колеги з державного
підприємства прозоро вони багато статей
пишуть Там воно все структуровано
згруповано можна там поцікавитися там є
і коментарі можна задавати можна
задавати питання до Міністерства
економіки і вони так само відкриті до
комунікації тому що ти там закупівлі
робіт як визначати то це зараз не дуже
до нас питання як тільки з'являться
роботи Ми теж вивчимо додатково і тоді
будемо І на це питання кон працювати
колеги знов Дякую Дякуємо вам
маринівський
маринівський заклад освіти Я так розумію
Доброго дня будуть додані засоби захисту
рослин якщо це стосується добрив я вам
рекомендую або попрошу зараз уточнити
вас що саме має це на увазі от або нам
відписати Ну не якесь там офіційне
повідомлення на нашу пошту чи кудись у
Facebook чи Зателефонувати сказати що
саме маєте на увазі чи написати ми
подивимось дамо зворотній зв'язок що
стосується добрив і всіляких там хімії
для обробки рослин тому плануємо теж на
жаль для вас напевно не найпопулярніша
категорія серед замовників Тому поки ще
немає її але ми плануємо ці категорії
теж додавати далі зозівський заклади
освіти Чи потрібно робити та
оприлюднювати обґрунтування по постанові
мінус 710 ми вже готові повністю до
цього запитання або у нас на попередніх
заходах про нього питали Ні не потрібно
Це лише у випадку Якщо ця постанова вона
по переговорній процедурі тому закупівля
за запитом цінових пропозицій та за
відкритими торгами вона без цього
здійснюється вам для того щоб ефективно
використовувати кошти не треба додатково
обґрунтовувати використання запиту
цінових пропозицій можна цього не робити
тут коли лише дякують Дякуємо за те що
долучилися Дякуємо за запитання колеги з
Хустського професійного ліцею пишуть з
ецп хороша річ коли буде зміни до закону
постанова 11,78 не безстрокова ну так ми
Нам би всім напевно хотіли не Напевно А
точно нам би всім хотілося щоб Постанову
11,78 якомога скоріше втратила чинність
не тому що вона така погана тому що це
означало б щоб ми перемогли в війні і
завершився військовий стан
Але дійсно поки що зцп лише на період
дії постанови 11,78 Я вже у презентації
казав якби це поки що лише анонс Але ми
з колегами з Міністерства освіти Я
перепрошую з Міністерства економіки
працюємо вже над питаннями щодо змін до
закону тому що розуміємо що війна
значним чином вплинула і треба
закупівельна законодавство
пристосовувати як Тетяна на початку
сказала і в принципі й до реалії і до
нормативки Європейського Союзу тому ми
орієнтуємося на те що зацп можна буде
використовувати і після нашої Перемоги і
в рамках закону принаймні всіх зусиль і
там дискутуємо і на всіх зустрічах всіх
колег з міністерства до цього якби
доводимо приклади кажемо про те що прошу
Вам сьогодні розповідали про
ефективність про всі ключові показники
про те які наші ідеї стосовно покращення
інструменту тому що очевидно що є що
покращувати і ми над цим працюємо
сподіваємося що нас почують начебто поки
чують і після прийняття змін до закону
зцп теж залишиться
[музика]
Ольга задає питання дуже важливе Ольга
питання звучить так Вітаю бачу колеги
вносять свої додаткові вимоги до
предмета закупівлі у примітках при зацп
на скільки це законно
це зараз не передбачено у нас на цей
рахунок є новина остання в контексті там
закупівель які зараз на шкільні автобуси
наприклад
проводяться і остання останній пост на
Facebook хто там зайшов То вже напевно
побачив стосовно того що зараз не
передбачено уточнення і там прописування
будь-яких додаткових технічних вимог
замовником за
який суперечать чи уточнюють профіль
специфікацію яку ми підготували якщо
серед специфікації розміщених у прозоро
маркет зараз немає підходящої для вас
якщо ви щось хотіли бутичнити
звертайтеся на майданчик у нас зараз є
можливість аналізувати ситуацію і
оперативно Буквально за декілька днів у
випадку потреби створювати таку
специфікацію щоб ви могли не самостійно
щось прописувати що насправді не є
законною непередбаченого нормативкою а
ми проаналізували і якщо це потреба
дійсно там коректно провалідована ми
можемо створити для вас цей профіль
тобто звертайтеся до майданчика якщо
немає специфікації такої як ви б хотіли
бачити ми її можемо для вас зробити
звертайтеся Якщо але це зрозуміло що не
системне вирішення питання тому як я вже
анонсував ми зараз працюємо над
технічними змінами і сподіваємося що вже
влітку цього року ми дамо замовнику
можливість до певної Суми скоріш за все
до 500 тисяч гривень уточнювати
характеристики тобто надаватимемо набір
характеристик А ви зможете власне
самостійно їх підібрати і зробити це в
системі не аби як вписати можливість
примітках а визначити це значить прямо
електронними полями тобто резюмуючи
зараз можете до нас звернутися ми
підготуємо специфікацію розмістимо її в
системі Поки що так можна щось уточнити
Якщо вам не вистачає того що я в системі
але по більшості товарів насправді має
вистачати Ну і закупівлі це показують а
в подальшому Ми плануємо надавати
замовникам таку можливість
Так тут колеги дякуюють і я думаю що ще
декілька запитань ми знайдемо серед
цього і напевно що будемо завершувати бо
колеги дякую дякую
дякую Щоб нічого не пропустити
Оксана задає запитання Добрий день Чи
можна трішки детальніше як купляти
електроенергію через ДЦП і як бути з
електроенергію для гуртожитків Дякую за
купівля
Ну от колеги діляться нюансами тому що
насправді щодо особливостей для
гуртожитків
я не готовий був відповісти на яку
нормативку посилатися саме для закупівлі
електричної енергії для гуртожитків
колеги зозівського ліцею пишуть про те
що закупівля має здійснюватись Без
застосування відкритих торгів та
електронного каталогу Тобто ви можете
колеги принаймні так посилаються на те
що можна здійснювати як я казав скоріш
за все за тарифами для населення це поза
системою відбувається
Добрий день Якщо за четвертим знаком
Суми закупівлі більше 100 тисяч гривень
а за кожною окремою позицією до 50 тисяч
гривень обов'язково робити з Зацепи чи
можна робити прямі закупки через кошик
Дивіться що стосується прямих закупівель
через кошик насправді якщо у вас дійсно
там аргументовано по кожної конкретною
окремої позиції до 50 тисяч то у нас
така нормативка раніше була Ну коли ми
працювали по закону коли там каналом
спроще це було так можна було
здійснювати закупівлю тобто яблука
окремо до 50 тисяч напряму купувати але
зараз ми бачимо певні
нюанси стосовно визначенням ціни
постачальниками на прямій замовлення
тому ми відмовляємося від прямих
замовлень найближчим часом можливо вже
там спочатку наступного місяця Як таких
тому найкраще все-таки за кожною
специфікацію проводити запит ці нових
пропозицій це і нормативно абсолютно
законно завжди купувати конкурентно
використовуючи запит ці нових пропозицій
так як зараз в нас все-таки вже 1178 діє
Ну і цей дозволяє найефективніше
найкраще кошти використовувати тому що
закупівля швидка якщо ми говоримо про
таку потребу той скоріш за все Ну я
підрозділ що це харчування таке там де
багато позицій Ну і ви можете це
ефективно купити колеги тут же дякуюємо
вам дуже очіку категорії будівельні
матеріали та будемо будемо
старатися якомога швидше Все начебто до
кінця запитання ми дійшли сподіваємося
що всі відповіді отримали якщо хтось не
встиг задати питання контакти ще є
Обирайте зручний для вас спосіб
задавайте будемо старатися відповісти на
цьому Я вже аж трохи навіть втомився
розмовляти передаючи слово євгену пане
Євген будь ласка Можливо щось додати
Дякую дім Дмитро має у нас унікальні
таланти окрім своїх професійних навичок
ще має унікальний таланти дуже довго і
цікавого розповідати да тому я тобі
дякую сподіваюсь що нашим слухачам
сьогодні також це сподобалось колеги і я
на правах реклами якщо можна
користуючись нагодою все ж таки Якщо вам
дійсно сподобалось прошу знайти нашу
сторінку на Фейсбуці Да і підписатись ми
були б дуже за це вам вдячні А що
стосується
в принципі прозоромаркету сьогоднішньої
нашої зустрічі Я сподіваюсь що це було
дуже цікаво Ну і
сподіваюсь що це для вас дійсно корисна
і дуже вірю в те що прозора маркет стане
вашим ну таким добрим надійним
помічником ваші повсякденній роботі Да
тому ми зі свого боку готові завжди вам
допомагати наскільки це можливо да
сподіваюсь ваше закупівлю будуть
цікавими та ефективними Дякую колегам за
те що допомогли нас сьогодні зібрати
таку кількість такого аудиторію це дуже
круто сподіваюсь ми зможемо ще не один
раз організувати подібний захід тому
Дякую всім
Ми теж з колегою зі свого боку в першу
чергу Дякуємо за змістовний вебінар
судячи з активності з кількості запитань
з того як там незважаючи на те що час
ніби як вже вичерпався і питання
відповіді на запитання дають люди все ще
є люди все ще цікавляться Але то ми там
зовсім небагато його залишили вебінар то
видається мені що це дійсно актуальна
тема людям
дійсно цікаво зі свого боку я додам що
Якщо раптом колеги у когось із вас
виникнуть додаткові запитання після
вебінару то та формочка яку я зробив Де
я збираю вас електронки з тим щоби
поширити вам запис вона зокрема містить
і поле де ви можете написати додаткові
запитання якщо вони будуть
якщо їх буде достатньо якщо колеги
погодяться ми які-небудь захід на
наступний ще такі самі організуємо
точно так само враховуючи зацікавленість
з публіки я дякую не лише
щоб правильно сказати так
професійні запитання з державної
установи професійні закупівлі Так
значить
також так вже хочу подякувати на
колегами закладів які
за делегували на цей захід дійсно людей
яким розбираються в темі Ще раз всім
Дякую за
час який приділили
посилання на анкету Я вже бачив Там
більше 80
відповідей є я от ще раз кінець Чак
обставлю Ще скільки
скількись часу воно потримається а
наразі Все всім нам Тихого Мирного
завершення робочого тижня і Хороших
ресурсних вихідних до зустрічі до
зустрічі до побачення
Дякуємо Гарного дня всім